I covered the walking dead non-stop and
I was constantly inundated with like the
really extreme fan response whether it
was positive or negative so I'm curious
you hear really heated responses to some
of the material how does that shape what
you do especially because you serve in a
variety of capacities on the show so
when you hear stuff like that would you
kind of take back to the group and say
now we're going to do this instead
listen to be really honest you know the
glenn and abraham episode was it was
rough I mean it was rough emotionally
for me because I remember reading the
comic book and seeing Glenn killed in
the comic book and I was really
disturbed by how senseless it felt in
that comic book like he just guy just
says uni meenie miney moe and and he was
gone and it really bothered me so when
the that moment came up in the show and
I was really tight with Michael Cudlitz
and really tight with Steven Yeun and I
knew that that was going to land on my
shoulders to direct that episode I you
know I went in and I did I directed the
best episode that I could direct knowing
that I was breaking breaking people's
hearts and and really sort of walking
right on that line but you know part of
what the show really is about in this
iteration of the show it really is about
that senseless that senseless
one minute they're there the next minute
they can be gone so it's it's hard
because I read a lot of great stuff
about it and I've read a lot of terrible
stuff about it and I would say there are
times when I agree with some of the
things that are said and we've had those
conversations there were things that
came up that I we had a conversation I
said mark my words some
is gonna publish an article about that
and in the episode airs and there's an
article and it's right there and and I
and and it's it's a little frustrating
sometimes but in other instances there
have been things that I ve disagreed
with you know like in the in the
original comic book when Shane dies in
season two Carl's the one that shoots
Shane and when we did the comic poem we
did the the TV show I remember it wasn't
Carl that shot chained and I remember
having a conversation with Robert
Kirkman and saying dude I remember I
remember that mom in it that that it was
Carl this little kid who had the gun who
ended up shooting Shane so there have
been times when I have kind of I pushed
back against some things and in a lot of
times yeah that works great and other
times it's like yeah that's not you know
like when when rick cut Meegan's throat
i directed that episode and I had said
to Scott Gimple the showrunner I think
Maggie should shoot him I think Maggie
Maggie should either kill negan or shoot
negan or do something because she's
right there
I said it's really hard it was really a
hard moment to shoot knowing that Maggie
collapses to her knees because Rick
spares negan's life that was really and
I sort of had pitched this idea to [ __ ]
I'm like why doesn't Maggie shoot him
why doesn't Maggie kill him and you know
obviously negan's character had more
more of a journey and there was a lot
more going on but you know the the
episode where Rick shows up in front of
the sanctuary with all the cars and
they're all shooting and nobody shot
anybody I kept saying can negan get shot
in the leg and it gets shot in the I
mean it you have a hundred people there
and none of them actually shot anybody
and I really I was sort of but even
Jeffrey was like come on man give me a
bullet hole in the shoulder or in the
leg or something and I'm like I would
love to shoot you and II was
like can I just shoot him like yeah we
should get shot him but and I when we
were shooting that episode I went I'm
gonna in there I'm gonna hear about it
I'm gonna hear about the baton army and
like a hundred people outside the
sanctuary not one of them actually hit
anybody and we did but you know but
listen the good news is the great news
is you know the shows the shows really
in a great place
you know I think Angela's done an
unbelievable job and I think that you
know with Samantha and Brian and all the
actors you know with Geoffrey and
Melissa and Norman and Elsie and
everybody you know it really it really
last two seasons have been really really
fun and the storytelling has just become
adrenaline
we don't take you know we don't take a
long time to sort of get to it you know
the story's really really move and I
think Angela's done a great job
you